love this guy one of my favorites that
i've gotten to meet in all my years with
the nfl network he is a head coach in
new orleans st
sean payton how are you coach rich i'm
doing well how are you
i'm better for talking to you how is
that draft how what number draft is this
for you
like grand total drafts uh that's a good
question 97 was my first one coming into
the league as a
as an assistant um
i think 20
i'm bad at math if i if i wasn't holding
the phone i'd be using my left finger
um it's a 25 quarter century 25 i think
quarter century of drafts
congratulations i know what you get
somebody for that i guess that's a
silver anniversary i'll get you
something silver
how about uh lombardi trophy how does
that sound yeah do you like that
another one would be great uh i
i i don't think they're just handing
those out but um
a lot happened this was this was unique
um relative to the draft process that
compared two other years uh
you know for players as well as scouts
and teams
um without the combine per se you know
the season
a lot of interrupted seven game
schedules five
games six games some players not playing
um the most notable thing
for us when the draft ended you're on
the phone with
a number of college free agents each
team is signing
uh a number of players that turn out to
be real good football players that
that number was almost down a thousand
no kidding just because of players
returning
for another season um
so the the size of the draft class was
smaller and i think conversely next
year when when we have our next draft i
think we're going to see a large
much larger class sean payton here on
the rich eisen show
um let's let's talk the the number of
reports i saw before the draft that you
were
trying to trade up into the top ten
quarterback
minded or potentially as mack jones was
falling
to middle of the draft to get him uh but
you stayed put
uh walk us through what happened on
draft night if you can yeah
it was pretty simple look we we felt
there were a couple players that
we'd move up for and for us we we have a
you know a mustache corner and so that
there were two corners graded
both horn and certain with real high
grades
um and very quickly you know early in
the week
um it's pretty common for teams to say
hey we have an interest you know
everyone's basically open for business
but ultimately
uh there wasn't a team wanting to move
out of
the first 10 picks and so
i think that lasted all of you know a
half an hour maybe
the the morning of reaching out to these
teams and and the cost would have been
if we found a trade partner too high so
uh
you know at that point our feeling was
uh
you know it's going to come to us at 28
and let's make sure we have our our
cloud of players ready
and it's exactly what happened so the
top 10
uh possibility was targeting a corner in
mind because of
it it was a corner but but i would say
this
if you make a trade
while you're well while you're not on
the clock or the or the club that you're
trading with
is not on the clock you you do have to
have some contingency plans
in the event that let's say both those
corners were taken before nine or eight
or where
wherever that trade took you if you if
you make one on the clock
you know your players available so i
think it was
look the beginning of this draft so much
time spent on the beginning of the draft
and everyone discusses it predicts it
you know it went fairly smooth i
i think the first pick that people were
split on or
not split but hey what was cincinnati
going to do were they going to take the
left tackle or the receiver and of
course they took the receiver so
i don't know that there were any real
real hiccups
certainly at three would quarterback
where the 49ers gonna take and then
after that it went fairly smoothly but
um but yeah there there really wasn't
much interest at all
uh in in anyone moving out in in our
mindset
at the start was was for a corner you
know
it and we we saw that that wasn't going
to happen quickly then we
we just stayed right where we're at so a
man
sean if if the saints had gotten jc horn
you would have had to nail the
pads and the goalposts down shut
wouldn't you
[Laughter]
right well he uh
he's a tremendous player and
unfortunately he's in our division i
think it's a good pick by carolina
that's right
um real he was a real competitive player
you saw it on film and
um you know did so many things well at
that position
um but we had we had an opportunity here
early on we coached joe his father
and yes uh i think they're different
type of uh
well they're they're both extremely
athletic but uh
personality wise there's probably some
uniquenesses that are different with
them but
um yeah all good though and i'm sure
joe's proud of him
sean payton here uh on the rich eisen
show let's talk about your
your quarterback depth chart um which
i'm sure you're uh familiar with talking
about
starting first with the fact i just want
to kick the tires on this
i remember you know when we talked on
this show
uh you know many many moons ago when
brees did
decide to come back that there was a
time where you thought like maybe he
wouldn't
uh was there a time at any point in time
where you thought maybe he would come
back
in the weeks that it took to finally
hear from drew on the subject
no i i think i think
this year it was
i don't want to say it was a certainty
but i i i think
we felt i think drew felt the same that
this was going to be his final season i
i only say that because we felt that way
um
last season when the season ended
you know he had kind of hinted about
maybe that being the year and so i
i think heading into this year i i i
think
uh i'm sure that i don't want to speak
for him but i'm sure he felt that way
and and we did the same
so your your depth chart is there a
competition
at the top or is this james this is gig
okay there is
there is i think both uh taysom and
jameis
you know are gonna have plenty of
opportunities once we get into
the training camp in the preseason games
you know to see those two guys compete
um trevor simeon is
i think still a young player that
uh i feel positive about he's on our
depth chart and then we just drafted ian
book
out of notre dame um
you know it's it's it's getting these
guys together and
look there's going to be three preseason
games and
the challenges you know do you have
enough reps there
but but i think look the that room has
been really good obviously withdrew in
it
you know when we had teddy bridgewater
here for a while
um you know with taysom and then when he
left we were able to sign
jameis and these guys are you know
pretty competitive but also
guys that get along and and football is
really important to him
well obviously if jameis is your starter
hill still has a role
um and if vice versa hill
gets the start then jameis would be in
the role that we saw him and i guess
when when hill was the
was the backup um uh to breeze when
brees was hurt last year or
is there a possibility you could do
something similar to what you
we even saw jameis come in and he went
down the field um
you know in the playoffs like is there
is there a possibility
do you think there is a possibility for
having a two quarterback system ever
in the nfl look i think
as much as i think the furthest we went
with that
would have been you know when everyone
was healthy and
taysom was playing oh
call it eight to ten plays maybe a
quarterback i would never
discount that but i would say this
you know he knows and and so does james
that
you know we're looking we're looking to
find the guy that's going to lead our
team this year
and that doesn't mean the other player
is not going to have a role
um but certainly it varies you know if
if if jamis is starting obviously taysom
has a role that
expands not only just offensively but on
special teams etc
and if it's the other way around it's
probably a little bit more limited
uh just relative to to what jameis would
do and then
you know i say young guys i mean i think
i consider trevor still young and
of course ian who's a rookie we'll see
what those guys have and
and uh you know we we've kind of had to
do it a little bit up to this point you
know two years ago
teddy played five games and then last
year
uh taysom played four um and we've been
beyond fortunate to to have gone 15
years with
you know uh all the things that drew has
provided at that position i mean
uh you know that's an amazing career and
so that
that transition has begun and
you know we we look at then a lot of
what we're going to do offensively based
on who's doing it and how do we put an
offense around
those players or that player so i i do
think there's a little bit influx rich
relative to
who's starting and then the roles each
player has
uh some of that will be training camp
driven saints head coach sean payton
here on the rich eisen show
what'd you see in ian book that made you
think okay let's get him
let's get him in the system let's figure
something out here with him man
the big games and you watch him time and
time again i think he's a good athlete
uh you know he's six foot
and man when it was a big i mean when it
was a big game in a competitive moment
in the pocket i saw him out of the
pocket make plays i think he's accurate
i like his decision making i think he's
a winner
and there were just enough enough good
things that kept coming up when you
watched him play you know his
first game against clemson uh
he's the you know the all-time
winningest quarterback at notre dame
history
and we asked that i mean that's that's
the function of that position lead your
team to scores
find a way to win games um he's a pretty
impressive guy
uh when you when you look at his journey
and
and then when you talk to anybody
coaches
scouts players uh
all the feedback is is off the charts
and so
you know we were at that point in the
draft where
we felt it matched his grade and and uh
i'm excited to work with him well i mean
daniel jeremiah as soon as you drafted
him
sitting on the draft set with me on nfl
network um
coach uh jumped up and you know and
obviously this is a height weight
comparison but brees he said he's he's
got the same
the same build the seeds like a carbon
copy is what he basically said
what do you think you know i i think
that's uh that's the first comparison i
think
it's it's an easy one when you when you
look at the statue
the the stature in um
i'm sure a little bit different they
played in a little bit different type
offenses in college but
periodically when you make a selection
during the draft
you might get a text from another gm or
another coach or someone who
you know in the industry and uh
that happens throughout the draft in in
and i can recall after that selection
the number of
gm's and coaches who i respect right
away and it was beyond just their
favorite hey in
even uh you know a
a well-respected retired general manager
who who right away said you might have
gotten one of the better quarterbacks in
the draft and and
uh the great thing is we get a chance to
find out
how's parcells is he is he somebody
who's texting you giving you thoughts
he he does uh it wasn't who i was
discussing but
he does and he was compromised a little
this year
because this was the first year the
draft fell on derby saturday
it's never happened before that's so hot
it's always been the week prior to the
derby right and so when
saturday came around and if you recall
we're in
the seventh round and
riders around riders up
like there were a lot of draft rooms
that had two tv sets going
were you one of them one of your drafts
absolutely we were we had a picture of
secretariat up in our draft room on
saturday
what what for just his inspiration
something like that honor
yeah honor the the one of the greatest
thoroughbred racehorses
ever and uh all right yeah we
we uh we put secretariat up and and
but we were in the seventh round and
actively involved in
a selection i i think
though i think to credit the the
networks they
that race went off a little later than
expected and it worked
worked for everyone it did and the few
minutes i have left with you sean payton
if you don't mind i want to hit
something competition committee i know
you're on it how do we get rid of the
fumbling through the end zone
is a ball that goes to the defense i i
can't stand it
i've you know you might have it you
might have a different you might have a
different
approach to it you know oh listen i hate
it i
yeah it it seems it seems odd
um but i would say it's probably
like 14th
on on on my list of things that drive me
crazy but that doesn't mean that it
shouldn't be higher up there
um you know we're getting ready to have
meetings with rookies
in our facilities here next weekend
and when they meet with us now they're
going to be out on the practice field
and they're going to be in the weight
room but when they meet with us we go
into our offices
and we send them to their meeting rooms
and we have a virtual meeting with them
and that'll be the first time we've ever
done that so that's number one on your
list is that what you're saying
but it's right it's right there with the
fumble into the end zone
okay um yeah i look i think it's been
discussed it's been brought up a lot
um you know it in it i feel like it
happens
three times a season right you know
and especially you know players today
are really gonna
they do a great job at diving for that
pylon touch the pylon
part of the pylon it's an aggressive
right it's an aggressive play that's
exciting that's what fans want to see
and i know
you know and coaches are are are
teaching you know players not to do that
coaching them not to do that because you
don't want to lose possession of the
ball that's why i'm saying let's
change it like a reverse back that if it
if it happens on third and goal it's now
third and goal from the 20 but you at
least get a shot at
throwing in the end zone making another
play getting the field goal out of it it
just
it seems to bail out a defense i hate it
we could we could go the route of like
shoots and ladders if it happens you're
back on your own 20 you go all the way
back to
like the beginning i love the shoots and
ladders i love that
i don't mind it it just it just drives
me crazy and it's going to happen in the
super bowl and the whole country
country's going to freak out
over it and then it'll really be number
one on your list of a competition
committee you know how that works yep
you know so it it is something that's
been discussed
and um and it's something that
you're right as a head coach it's one of
the situations that we discuss
during training camp we'll bring it up
we'll try to
attack the outside of the pylon you know
with the idea that
any any type of fumble would be
outside of it out of bounds as opposed
to inside of it touch back
um yeah
there are just a few of these and and
look each year we seem to be able to
grab one or two of them but this one i
i know this one's been debated and
discussed a lot
and as is the rule where if a defender
when the ball is fumbled into the end
zone bats it out of the end zone it's a
foul
and uh you know there are other times
where he can bat it
and it's not a foul but but when he bats
it out of the back of the end zone
uh that it's that it's a foul so i
look e it it comes up and when it comes
up in a bigger game
you know how that is yes the squeaky
wheel will get the grease when it's time
but
um but in the meantime we coach around
or we discuss it we understand it and i
would agree with you it is an exciting
play especially
with today's athlete and they're so in
tune to that you know that
basically that that line that goes
around the world and the vertical
portion of the cone the ain't piece of
it it's a score i mean
they're all diving for it last one for
you
home team coming to netflix apparently
um about your year off
from the nfl coaching your son's youth
team and
kevin james as sean payton is that a
fact
it is it's um
it's a project that that started gosh
over a year and a half two years ago and
chris tytone
who is my daughter's boyfriend wrote
wrote this with a partner
after seeing a little special done on
nfl network just about
oh that sixth grade team where are they
now and and so
one thing led to another and adam
sandler and his group at netflix and
kevin james and
they began to look closely at the
project and decided to
uh to do it and jump jump forward now
to today wednesday may 5th uh all the
production people are here the filming
people are here that they begin this
whole week they'll be here for two
months
i've really not had anything to do with
this even in the writing of it
um but it's a i think a comedy feel good
story
that that adam always does a great job
with and
kevin and those guys they always uh
have some entertain entertaining movies
and
it's about uh yeah it's about me
coaching this sixth grade team
and but there's a ton of look it's
inspired by a true story and then i'll
leave it at that because
after reading it myself there's all
sorts of funny stuff in there
and uh it was a it was a
it was a good season having a chance to
work with with those guys and and really
going all the way back to
you know you're cutting oranges you're
mixing gatorade you're coming to the
practice you're
putting air in the footballs you're
you're doing everything
and you're also getting to do it with
your son and and
that meant a lot for me well you know i
can't wait to see it
um and i can't wait to see so he is
literally
it is you though right like he it's
kevin james as sean payton
yeah okay he's actually uh yeah he's
he's playing that rock
that part there there are a few other
characters uh
that are playing different people in in
the movie and
and kevin is playing uh the coach though
yeah he's
terrific we've talked a few times
already we had we've had a zoom we'll do
some more
um you know development relative to he's
got a few things he wants to discuss and
um he seems like a fantastic guy he is
he's a jet fan he's a die-hard jet fan
so you can you can talk about new york
sports
yes it is listen i didn't know that and
uh oh yeah
well we'll have to we'll have to work on
him a little bit but i know he lives in
new york
in florida that's right and uh oh yeah
and i know he's he's excited about the
the project
well it's a it's a it's a great story i
know you've you've uh you've spoken
about it before and i can't wait to see
it and i appreciate the time as always
sean let me know when you're here in los
angeles i'd love to see you
rich the the feeling is mutual and uh
always
always great to be on i really
appreciate you mikey right back at you
that's sean payton saints head coach the
hd of the new orleans saints at sean
payton on twitter i follow him you
should
follow him too hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here